yeah new five-minute game let's see what
happens upon it from ya from Brazil now
it nowadays you can set up the flag that
you actually want some free to to choose
pretty high rated and we got the Kings
gambit ok I'll try for this fun counter
gambit there are sometimes employ and
bully chess it sir I don't know maybe a
bit what well this is straight away
losing for white what the heck is he
doing yeah this is cool I mean I one
time one quite a number of games with
this already in bullet chess but against
some guy rated almost 2,400 here in five
minutes this is really really a really
weird yeah okay come on let's exchange
Queens I'll win with the lookup White
Rose I yeah this is officially the
biggest at the quickest whenever I think
am I in all of my five-minute Jessia so
it's a very brief video but ok it so
it's a bit silly to to end it after 1
minute 30 i can what i'll do is i'll
show you briefly the ideas behind this
really creates it looking gambit it's
not again but really it so it's a yeah
yeah crazy ok let's let's explain a bit
what's happening a white has two moves
that that are really bad the worst move
was the one that he played night xe5
after you can take neither Queen to h4
and you accept exactly what happens
after g3 is losing the rook and this
stuff here is not much better white also
I mean you can you can step 2 2 g-3 but
this kind of stuff gets get simply mated
to look at this year I'm hotel you can
so i can get go here and so i think you
get made it somehow like this this chick
made yeah it's very very close to
checkmate so on this line that he that
he played is really the worst get some
back to to the position now here 95 is
the worst move I'm similarly bad as f
takes e4 because after this when item
doesn't have any decent squares it
cannot go anyway active and white is
just yeah he's forced to retreat our
sacrifices piece I mean something like
this it looks rather funny like a Scott
the next opponent less the night
available and why does nothing I'm so
very often people who stumble into this
accidentally try to make a piece
sacrifice out of this but after this
like is just winning this kind of stuff
it's just just a piece for nothing so
this both recaptures only five simply
loose basically lose the game so on what
should why do what is play was
definitely is taking on on f5 to which
black plays a form and after 95 like has
yeah more than one movie even you can
play the someone with looking 27 I play
Knight f6 usually and with the intention
of pushing away the night so we
sometimes get get things like this let's
put it this way and it's rather unclear
i mean you can you can play this but i
only played this in bullet chess usually
so it's not like i have huge analysis on
this um some theoreticians even claim
that the best move should be
d3 here but of course this cannot really
a trouble black attempt 96 and just play
a play on its own certainly am not
life-threatening lyst III move by the
way deform is also very very fine for
black doesn't have any of any kind of
problems will push away the the night
with t6 and no problems yeah if you look
for an offbeat line and the King's
gambit you might investigate this it's I
don't think it's refuted or anything
it's just somewhat risky and
weird-looking and you can really catch
people sometimes who don't know don't
know about the opening one thing you
need to take into account is though in
this position white can also go here and
you end the BNI game with 96 and
probably this is not what you usually
play because some while I'd say here the
90 of 60 is the normal muth intending to
go for this this line but p.m. your this
position you would reach this position
here and this is really a difference on
22 the Kings gambit assume you have this
early knight on c3 year so it said it's
a different line alright so just some
some reefer theoretical on the points
about this crazy line yeah thanks for
watching